So I talked about that having a job we
love is a right, not a privilege
but there are many people who push back
and say to me,
"Yeah but having a job you love really is a luxury
and a lot of people just need a job to survive."
At some level everybody needs a job to survive
and regardless of what our needs are
and where we work,
wouldn't we rather work for companies that care about us as human beings?
A company doesn't have to be glamorous for us to
love the work.
There are many companies that do
glamorous things
that are terrible places to work
and there are lots of companies
that do some pretty mundane things
that just make some random widget,
that are wonderful places to work.
This is what my whole movement is about.
I want to create change,
I want to drive change in the business world,
so that everyone,
regardless of what our income is,
regardless of what we're making,
regardless what our position inside the organization is,
that every single one of us gets to work at a place
where we feel that people
view us and treat us like human beings
rather than some disposable thing on a
financial statement.
So to all those people who say,
"Yeah but some people just need a job to survive."
I say, absolutely.
And they should have the opportunity to work in a place
that they love going to work also.